euer
aktivstar lieblings Instagram influenza
sich mal wieder eine richtig coole und
vor allem
auch die Idee für ein Youtube Video
einfallen lassen denn wir machen heute
ein
Q&A
danke damit ihr allerdings nicht die
ganze Zeit hier im Full Stream meine
hässliche Fresse angucken müsst habe ich
mir gedacht machen wir so richtig auf
2012 angelehnt einfach einen kommentari
ich habe minecraft Jump and Run gespielt
und das läuft jetzt einfach hier neben
während ich Fragen beantworte und von
daher starten auch direkt mit der ersten
Frage warum ziehst du zurück nach
Bielefeld habe ich im Podcast gehört ich
würde dir erstmal hno-termin empfehlen
weil ich das nie gesagt habe vielleicht
verwechselst Du mich mit Sandra kann
schon mal vorkommen wir sehen uns
relativ ähnlich sandra ist tatsächlich
vor einigen Wochen zurückgezogen nach
Bielefeld sonst in die Heimat wenn ich
zurückziehen würde wird tatsächlich
stabile Feld heißen
ja es ist momentan nicht geplant mein
größtes live goal ist immer noch
irgendwann mal in die Schweiz zu ziehen
weil die Schweiz meiner Ansicht nach das
lebenswerteste allerdings auch das
schönste Land in Deutschland ist
allerdings besitze ich ja bereits über
sowas rede ich aber nicht Immobilien in
Bielefeld in unserer Heimat und hätte
die Möglichkeit dorthin zu ziehen
worüber ich auch sehr sehr dankbar bin
und plane da auch was zu bauen werde
dort jetzt allerdings nicht in den
nächsten Jahren hinziehen ich bin so
grounded und gefestigt in Köln mit all
meinen Freunden und dem Viertel hier und
allem ich bin total happy hier und seh
mich auf jeden Fall die nächsten Jahre
erstmal hier mental und körperlich zur
Zeit geht mich würde es sehr
interessieren erstmal danke schön für
die Frage ich finde es immer sehr sehr
schön wenn Leute dieses wie geht's dir
wirklich sehr sehr ernst meinen und
nicht so wie geht's dir alles Gute bei
dir auch alles gut zu Ende sondern
wirklich oder erzähl mal wirklich so wie
geht's dir so das ist eine sehr schöne
Frage und die wichtigste Frage
eigentlich und die kam auch sehr sehr
häufig deswegen danke an alle die das
gefragt haben ich fühle mich körperlich
auf jeden Fall bei einer 100%. ich bin
so fit wie noch nie ich bin so gesund
wie noch nie ich trinke so wenig Alkohol
wie noch nie irgendwie so wenig raus wie
noch nie natürlich macht immer noch viel
mit Freunden so ich liebe das einfach
rausgehen und Bars gehen etc aber
einfach dann auch früh zu Hause sein fit
sein Sport durchziehen ich mache seit 60
Tagen jeden Tag Sport und ähm ja bin
körperlich so fit wie ich noch nie war
und mental würde ich sagen bin ich sogar
dafür 85 %. worüber ich aber auch sehr
stolz bin weil vor dem halben Jahr war
ich noch so bei 0% fast da war ich
richtig am Ende aber ich bin
mittlerweile mental so gefestigt auch
und
überdenkt jede Entscheidung und bin
mittlerweile in so einem state of mine
dass ich wirklich in jeder Situation
relativ schnell dreimal überlege okay
wie wird das auf andere wie sollte ich
antworten wie sollte ich reagieren und
nicht mehr so aus dem Effekt und der
Emotion raus handle und daraus irgendwie
reagiere sondern wirklich erstmal mich
hinsetzen nachdenke überlege jetzt nicht
wirklich sondern in Word eben
übertragenen Sinne dass ich mich
hinsetzt aber wenn irgendwer was sagt
ist nicht in sondern normalen Situation
mit Kollegen wenn man draußen unterwegs
ist oder so sondern wenn man irgendwie
eine schwierige Situation dass man dann
relativ schnell alles hinterfragt und so
da bin ich sehr stolz drauf aber es
fehlen noch Prozente bis ich sagen würde
okay ich bin mental wieder komplett bei
100% wie oft kochst du selber und wie
zufrieden bist du mit deinen Kochkünsten
im Gegensatz zu meiner Studienzeit vor
fünf sechs Jahren koche ich mittlerweile
tatsächlich täglich früher war das
wirklich so da konnte ich an einer Hand
abzählen wie oft ich im Monat gekocht
habe weil ich einfach nicht die Zeit
hatte ich dann irgendwas bestellt und es
gab vor allem auch noch nicht so Sachen
wie Gorillas flink etc wo du halt
Lebensmittel bestellen kannst in der
Großstadt und halt einfach die selber
frisch etwas kochen kannst mittlerweile
ist es aber auch so ein bisschen mit
Training geschuldet so ich es und muss
täglich auch meine 4000 Kalorien essen
und dann möchte ich einfach wissen was
drin ist und wenn ich irgendwo was
bestellt weiß ich nicht okay sind als
geschmacksversteiger drin wurde mit dem
Öl gekocht ist der dies ist da das drin
was ist in der Sahne was das für eine
Soße blablabla wenn man selber kocht
weiß ich ganz genau die Kartoffel habe
ich geschält aber ist das nur eine
Kartoffel im Kopf Ende und das ist eine
ganz schöne Ansicht und ähm mittlerweile
habe ich halt mein Alltag so
strukturiert und so im Griff dass ich
genau weiß dann und dann wird gekocht
dann bisschen was übrig ist wird das
eingewandbasis und da bin ich sehr sehr
froh drüber also ich bin zufrieden mit
meinen Kochkünsten ihr kennt aber auch
meine Ansicht ich finde Kochen braucht
kein Talent es braucht eine Übung so ein
guter Koch kann einfach nur Gerichte
auswendig weil nach einem Rezept kann
jeder kochen und äh Kochen tue ich
selber täglich könntest du bitte ein
Video über deine Ernährung und Fitness
Programm machen thanks lieber Friedrich
diese Frage wurde mir tatsächlich mit am
meisten gestellt von den ganzen Fragen
in meiner Instagram Story und ich werde
das klipp und klar beantworten
nö ich werde das vielleicht irgendwann
mal machen jetzt gerade allerdings noch
nicht weil ich mich selber noch nicht in
der Situation fühle als ob ich euch
jetzt richtig was mitgeben könnte ich
lerne selber jeden Tag über Fitness über
Sport über meinen Körper ich bin selber
wöchentlich beim Osteopathen lass mich
da behandeln und so und habe in den
letzten Monaten einfach gemerkt wir
haben nur einen Körper und solche Sachen
wie eine Zahnreinigung oder aber zum
Osteopathen gehen oder wenn man eine
Runde gehen draußen oder täglich Sport
machen oder so ich habe war immer schon
sportlich klar ich habe alle Sportarten
die es irgendwie gibt habe ich schon
gemacht im Verein aber dieses krasse
gesundheitsempfinden das kann man mehr
als in den letzten Monaten und Wochen
deswegen lerne ich selber noch dazu und
wenn ich dann wirklich denke ich bin am
Ende ich weiß alles über meinen Körper
und jetzt kann ich wirklich Leuten was
mitgeben dann wird auch mal so ein Video
kommen äh ernährungstechnisch kann ich
euch vielleicht mal so ein bisschen was
vorkochen und so ein paar Sachen zeigen
wenn ihr da Bock drauf habt aber ich
sehe mich jetzt nicht als Fitness
Influenza der jetzt irgendwie seine
Tipps raushaut weil ich da selber noch
keine richtigen habe wirst du manchmal
kritisiert weil du Youtuber bist und
keinen echten Job hast nein
wenn überhaupt dann mal im Internet von
irgendwelchen Rambos hinter einem
Fake-Namen die sich denken rudert ja
noch nie gearbeitet aber wirklich Kritik
im echten Leben von wirklichen Personen
habe ich noch nie bekommen weil jeder
der in meinem Umfeld ist weiß dass ich
am meisten arbeite von allen Leuten klar
ist es keine physische Arbeit im Sinne
von ich trage einen Stein von hier nach
hier oder ich stehe am Band oder ich
mache dies oder das ich sitze am PC klar
aber das tue ich halt jeden Tag 365 Tage
im Jahr ich hatte dieses ganze Jahr lang
was wirklich jetzt schon fast sechs
Monate rum sind also in dem kompletten
halben Jahr hatte ich tatsächlich kein
einziger Urlaubstag bisher ich ähm weiß
auch dass wenn ich mal in den Urlaub
fahre für beispielsweise eine Woche weiß
ich auch die Woche davor habe ich
doppelt so viel zu tun es ist nicht so
wie in einem anderen Job ey man arbeitet
ganz normal und dann hat man seine
gesetzlich festgelegten Urlaubstage und
sagt dann kommen jetzt hör ich auf jetzt
mache ich zwei Wochen Urlaub sondern bei
mir wenn ich quasi im Urlaub bin mache
ich davor doppelt so viel damit für euch
halt Content kommt und ich meine ich
liebe das ja auch das ist ja nicht nur
mein Job sondern halt auch mein Hobby
deswegen fällt es mir selber nicht so
richtig auf manchmal wenn Freunde mir
sagen hey Bruder es ist jetzt Sonntag
wir konnten die ganze Woche lang nichts
machen jetzt das was machen lass mal den
PC jetzt aus und nach dem Motto ich
liebe das aber ich liebe meinen Job und
ich glaube dann geht das auch so ein
bisschen ineinander über dass man Spaß
daran hat aber das auch Arbeit ist und
dann bin ich auch sehr sehr froh darüber
aber Kritik bekomme ich nicht weil ich
weiß das ist ein richtiger Job ist ich
finde es manchmal ein bisschen schade
wenn alle Influenza bei einem Kamm
geschert werden und sich dann
irgendwelche Mädels angeschaut werden
die da in Dubai rumfliegen oder in
Amerika und die ganze Zeit nur im Urlaub
machen sind dann ist natürlich schade
wenn andere Leute das von außen sehen
und ich denke an die ganzen Influenza
die machen ja nichts weil es gibt
wirklich auch Leute also wo ich zum
Beispiel auch krass Respekt war das so
ein äh die Keller Elias dass der z.B
auch am durchziehen ist und ich würde
mich da auch mit einordnen oder andere
Platte die da jeden Tag im Livestream
sind das sind schon wirklich kranke Jobs
und da geraten Leute Recht an ihre
Grenzen ich selber hatte auch schon mal
einen Burnout und wenn irgendjemand
meint dass es kein echter Job ist
[__] you der John fragt wie ich mein
Geld investiere und wie ich für mein
Alter Vorsorge also in erster Linie
arbeite ich natürlich ich verdiene noch
aktiv Geld und auf der anderen Seite
natürlich ist auch mein Geld sehr gut
investiert würde ich sagen eine Ansicht
nach jeder hat er eine andere Ansicht Öl
man sollte das reinstecken immer sollte
diesmal sollte das wenn ich auf alle
gehört hätte dann wäre ich jetzt Pleite
allein was mir irgendwelche doodleys
erzählt haben mit irgendwelchen ich weiß
nicht mehr wie das heißt diese Bild nfcs
diese Bilder die da gemalt wurden die
aber digital waren das ist ja alles
eingebrochen Bitcoin was das
eingebrochen ist in den in letzter Zeit
das ist ja auch unfassbar also wenn ich
darauf alle schnellen Züge um irgendwie
schnell Cash zu machen aufgesprungen
werden dann wäre ich jetzt Pleite ich
bin da ziemlich oldschool und sagt er so
Schuster bleibt bei deinen Leisten
auch richtig ja aber ähm ich bin da ganz
solide aufgestellt ich habe meine paar
Immobilien ich habe andere Wege wo ich
investiert habe beispielsweise was
Aktien angeht oder auch Uhren habe ich
einige das sind aber eher so
Kleinigkeiten aber zum großer wirklich
eine Immobilien weil ich wirklich auch
Interesse an Architektur habe wenn man
so ein Konstrukt mittlerweile aufgebaut
was ganz gut läuft und darüber quatsch
ich eigentlich nie weil darum soll es
doch nicht gehen auf meinem Kanal bei
mir ihr merkt ja schon dass das heutige
Video so ein bisschen mehr real Talk ist
vielleicht auch mal wieder Bock drauf
hatte und viele haben mich gefragt hey
Luca so ich mache nie so Instagram Frage
unten weil ich das immer so ein bisschen
selbst erstellen findest so ich sehe
mich jetzt nicht als Barack Obama oder
Justin Bieber der übelst interessant ist
aber viele Leute hatten Fragen deswegen
ja so investiere ich mein Geld welche
Trennung hatte ich am meisten
mitgenommen er möchte dass ich seinen
Namen zensiere deswegen habe ich das
hier in dem Fall auch getan bisher aber
Dinge zu fragen habe ich nichts zensiert
aber ich hoffe ihr seid okay damit ähm
war der jetzt aber auch keine schlimmen
Fragen also ich hoffe das alles cool
die Trennung die mich am meisten
mitgenommen hat war tatsächlich die mit
Jule da bin ich auch ganz ehrlich da
schäme ich mich jetzt auch nicht für
dass ich das jetzt irgendwie so sage
oder so weil wir uns halt im guten
getrennt haben wir haben beide einfach
gesagt er guck mal sie kam aus Kiel war
bei mir in Köln
die war so weit weg von zu Hause und
dann haben wir beide halt gesagt komm es
ergibt irgendwie Sinn wenn wir uns
trennen weil sie hat noch diese
Verbindung mit zu Hause und ich bin hier
und vielleicht später noch mal
irgendwann und wir waren noch lange Zeit
dann noch am Schreiben und gut
befreundet sind immer noch Kontakt mit
Freunden von mir teilweise mit meiner
Mom schreibt sie noch so alles cool aber
das hat mich auf jeden Fall am meisten
mitgenommen weil da halt einfach nichts
vorgefallen ist was mich halt zu dem
trennungsschritt bewegt hat sondern wir
einfach in beiderseitigen Einverständnis
gesagt haben hey guck mal wir brauchen
das jetzt mal so dann beide haben
geheult wir haben uns getrennt und wir
wussten eigentlich so keine Ahnung es
war halt eigentlich so nicht wirklich
was magst Du es Freestyle zu tanzen und
zu singen willst du mal einen Song im
Studio auf dem Bro nein auf gar keinen
Fall
ich hasse es zu tanzen ich hasse es zu
singen und ich würde auch niemals den
Song aufnehmen ihr werdet von mir keinen
Ballermann Track bekommen so das machen
wir mittlerweile auch voll viele alle
fangen an zu rappen machen jetzt Eis
tätigen Julien BAM no from jo alles easy
der hat jetzt auch ein Eis Tee also ich
ihr seit einem Jahr geht jetzt zwar
nicht um die Frage hier habe ich arbeite
seit einem Jahr oder mittlerweile ein
Jahr und fünf Monate an einem Produkt
was bald in den Supermarkt hoffentlich
kommen wird wir wollen uns überhaupt
nicht stressen durch irgendwas weil wir
wissen es wird das beste Produkt in
seiner Branche sein und dann ist es egal
so wir müssen jetzt nicht den
tausendsten Eistee rausbringen aber ich
finde einfach dieses Bro habe ich gerade
schon gesagt schuster bleib bei deinen
Leisten wenn du Youtuber bist warum
fixieren ich finde das hat bei keinem
wirklich gut geklappt außer vielleicht
bei Shirin David aber ihr neues wieder
denke ich mir auch so hey
dieser toxische Männer hast der muss
halt auch nicht sein ich will ihn nicht
politisch werden aber von mir wird auf
jeden Fall kein Sorgen kommen um die
Frage zu beantworten deine Tattoos und
deren Bedeutung ich habe drei Tattoos
seit mittlerweile anderthalb Jahren
einmal hier so ein kleines Kreuz weil
ich gläubig bin ich will jetzt auch
keine glaubensdiskussion Anrede in den
Kommentaren die könnt ihr mal schreiben
ob ihr Glaube oder nicht das wird mich
echt mal interessieren ich bin gläubig
weil ich das brauche einfach irgendwie
so blöd das vielleicht klingt ich kann
mir natürlich und man kann sich auch
alles vernünftig biologisch erklären wo
wir herkommen und wie alles entstanden
ist und was weiß ich was aber mir gibt
es einfach Frieden wenn ich weiß ich
nicht abends im Bett und ich bete und
ich stelle mir vor dass da oben jemand
ist der mir zuhört und das alles aus dem
Grund passiert und so
urteilt nicht es ist einfach meine
Ansicht so glaub dann was ihr wollt mir
scheißegal dann habe ich hier noch ein
Tattoo das als LX IV das ihr mir aber
schräg gemacht damit quasi einerseits
LXI Farbe auch LX wenn das wieder
wegfallen würde V bedeuten kann
das ist eine römische Zahl und steht für
64 65 das sind die Geburtsjahre meiner
Eltern und dann habe ich noch ein Tattoo
auf meinem Oberschenkel das kann ich
jetzt nicht zeigen welche lange Hose an
habe da steht einfach ein Spruch drauf
nämlich jeden Morgen motiviert das werde
ich aber weg lasern lassen da gibt es
mittlerweile relativ gute Methoden das
werde ich im Herbst Winter durchführen
lassen und dann hoffentlich in einem
halben Jahr ja damit durch sein weil
damit kann ich nicht mehr so ganz
identifizieren lieber so berühmt wie
jetzt oder unbekannter normaler Mensch
ich ähm bleibe so wie ich bin bin ich
ganz ehrlich ich lebe jetzt mein Leben
hier ich bin froh darüber klar es ist
Fluch und singen zugleich wenn du
bekannt bist ich bin jetzt natürlich
keine Angela Merkel die durch alle
Bevölkerungsschichten
mäßig durch und durch bekannt ist und
gar nicht mehr irgendwo hingehen kann
aber ich merke es natürlich schon wenn
ich irgendwo in Köln unterwegs bin in
Bars in in Clubs da ist es zum Beispiel
mit am meisten mittlerweile seit dem
Podcast weil uns viele so Studenten auch
hören
dann nervt es natürlich immer mal so ein
bisschen wenn Leute gucken und du halt
weißt okay kannst jetzt nicht irgendwie
wie ein normaler Mensch irgendwie dein
Getränk bestellen sondern wenn irgendwas
ungeschüttet wird dann filmt das
vielleicht einer und blabla aber ich
komme damit mittlerweile relativ gut
klar ich bin auch froh dass es bei mir
nicht so
gegangenheit ich bin da plötzlich und
dann bin ich zack wieder weg sondern es
ist ja bei mir seit zehn elf Jahren
stetig äh ganz langsam am Wachsen und
das ist ganz schön dieser Entwicklung
und das so viele von euch auch auf
dieser Reise hier mit dabei sind
manchmal vermisst man natürlich so die
Vorteile wenn man quasi komplett anonym
ist aber ich bin froh wie ich bin und
möchte auch eigentlich nichts ändern
datest du gerade jemanden diese Frage
wurde natürlich auch sehr sehr häufig
gestellt ich weiß nicht wie man sich so
für das Liebesleben von irgendwelchen
Influenza interessieren kann bei mir ist
es scheiß egal wer was mit irgendwem hat
oder wer am Date ist oder so aber ich
werde dazu keine Auskunft mehr geben ich
habe das meinem Podcast gesagt dann ging
das direkt auf die Talker online ich
habe dann am Ende Story gepostet
letztens hier dann ging das auch bei die
Talker online seller danke schön kannst
auch gerne sein lassen es ist wirklich
nicht interessant glaube ich dass juckt
auch niemanden aber ich werde dazu bald
etwas sagen wenn der Spruch ist bis
dahin jetzt privat gehalten aber wenn
Spruch ist verspreche ich euch hiermit
an alle und euch dies unbedingt wissen
wollen werde ich auch öffentlich machen
weil ich selber aus der Vergangenheit
weiß dass man in meiner Position
zumindest eine Beziehung nicht geheim
halten kann viele sagen immer die wohl
Aufmerksamkeit nee ich möchte dann
einfach nur mit meinem Mädel Hand in
Hand rumlaufen können ohne dass
irgendwer ein Foto davon macht und das
ist gepostet wird weil dann heißt es
wieder oh die haben extra das in
inszeniert und blabla nein ich mache
nichts um Aufmerksamkeit zu bekommen es
ist mir scheißegal ob ich dabei lande
oder bei irgendwelchen anderen Influenza
Seiten oder bei promiflas weiß ich was
ich habe hier keinen Plan um irgendwie
bekannt zu werden ich lade eine tiktoks
hoch um irgendwie Hinweise zu streuen
oder irgendwie meine Gefühle damit
auszudrücken wenn ich Stress mit
jemandem habe oder irgendwie das mache
ich nicht ich mache mein Content ich
möchte Leute unterhalten und nur darum
soll es gehen wie motiviert
du dich jeden Tag zu trainieren hast du
da ein paar Tipps schau in den Spiegel
es gibt natürlich Youtube Videos die du
dir angucken kannst und Motivation als
Videos die kann ich mittlerweile alle
auswendig du kannst hier Filme angucken
die dich motivieren Creed z.B die Reihe
ist sehr sehr krass die Conor McGregor
Doku gerade sehr krass generell Sportler
Dokus einfach oder kurze Youtube Videos
wenn du dir ein Training anguckst von
LeBron oder solchen Leuten das motiviert
natürlich heftig aber ich finde was am
meisten motiviert ist wenn du dich im
Spiegel anguckst und wirklich einfach
denkst oder merkst hey guck mal da geht
was so und man will nicht mehr so
aussehen wie man gerade aussieht das
motiviert mich immer mit am meisten hast
du schon mal darüber nachgedacht eine
Psychotherapie zu machen ich mache das
tatsächlich seit dreieinhalb Jahren
das in Hamburg bei einem Herrn gemacht
und habe das damals ein bisschen
schleifen lassen bin dann aber nach Köln
gezogen und macht das jetzt hier auch
bei einer Dame und kann nur sagen dass
das auf jeden Fall deutlich besser läuft
als noch in Hamburg ich bin sehr sehr
happy momentan und kann auch einfach nur
sagen dass das Beste ist was man
irgendwie machen kann und auch wenn bei
dem Leben alles super läuft immer zu
einer Therapeutin so also meiner Ansicht
nach können Therapeutinnen das besser
als ein Therapeut habe ich so das Gefühl
ist eine Frau oder irgendwie offener ist
und dass man sich einer Frau also zum
Sicherheitstyp mehr hingezogen fühlte
meine also jetzt nicht ne auf sexueller
Basis sondern mehr hingezogen fühle
wirklich mich zu öffnen als meine Mann
das soll ich diskriminieren wirken gegen
Männer ne ich will nicht die Shirin
David machen aber das kann ich wirklich
jedem nur empfehlen und ich nehme auch
kein Plattform und ne also viele
sträuben sicher davor so etwas zu sagen
ich habe einfach so ein
Selbstbewusstsein dass ich über alles
reden kann so ich habe Probleme ich habe
auch psychische Probleme also ich gehe
dahin alles cool und
ja generell könnt ihr mich ne ich
quatsche über alles außer Geld bei Geld
da finde ich so das ist meiner Ansicht
so ein bisschen ich finde es natürlich
schön wenn wenn Youtuber darüber reden
und so alles cool wenn die sagen was sie
verdienen und so alles easy man kann
sich eh denken was ich verdiene so wenn
man das wissen möchte aber ich möchte
das selber nicht wissen bei anderen
Leuten die ich kennenlernen weil ich
Mensch nicht daran festmachen möchte was
ich verdienen dementsprechend einen
anderen Respekt dann irgendwie
vielleicht vor einer Person habe oder
keine Ahnung was sondern der Respekt
sollte nur darauf beruhen wie er sich
die gegenüber verhält habe ich auch
schon häufig gesagt mir scheißegal ob du
blaue Haare hast oder ob du die
Hautfarbe hast oder auf Frauen oder
Männer stehst oder ob du gern in eine
Flasche rein wichst so es ist mir
scheißegal hauptsache du bist nett und
du bist korrekt das ist jetzt vielleicht
ein bisschen hart ausgedrückt dann alle
unter euch ein bisschen jünger sind oder
wenn Eltern die gerade mit zuschauen
aber so ist es einfach
Mensch muss korrekt sein und ich finde
einen Menschen nicht korrekt aber jetzt
das verdient oder dies verdient und
deswegen will ich ja diese Geldfrage
einfach nur so das ist nicht mein alman
deutsches von wegen oh der will nicht
über Geld reden sondern ich finde
einfach es bringt einem gar nichts und
Geld sollte einfach nur da sein um sich
was zu essen zu kaufen und Ende was
macht ihr am meisten Angst wenn du an
die Zukunft denkst und das ist auch die
letzte Frage für das heutige Video eine
sehr schöne Frage weil so um die Zukunft
geht ich sehe auch gerade ich bin in der
hofaufnahme bei mittlerweile fast 40
Minuten muss das gleich noch mal gut
runterschneiden aber ich hatte einfach
mal Bock ein bisschen zu quatschen es
müssen ruhiger geworden das Video aber
ja zurück zu Frage was mir am meisten
Angst macht wenn ich an die Zukunft
denke ist tatsächlich der Tod meiner
Eltern wenn ich mich für eine Sache
entscheiden müsste weil ich das bei
vielen und leider zu vielen Leuten in
meinem Umfeld mitbekommen dass da
gesundheitliche Probleme schon langsam
geht bei den Eltern meine Eltern gehen
jetzt auch auf die 60 zu und ich liebe
meine Eltern über alles wir haben super
schönes Familienverhältnis und ich
möchte einfach nicht dass das
auseinandergerissen wird so alles ist
also alles kommt und geht nur der Tod
bleibt oder wie heißt das alles ist
umsonst nur der Tod nee nichts umsonst
nur der Tod oder irgendwie sowas so
jeder Mensch stirbt irgendwann mal das
ist einfach Fakt und da habe ich am
meisten Angst vor wenn ich es auch in
die Zukunft denke weil finanziell geht's
mir gut ich bin gesundheitlich fit ich
habe meine Freunde ich ähm es ist alles
super und das ist so das was mir am
meisten Angst macht aber gut meine Damen
und Herren danke schön für eure Fragen
wenn ihr auch Fragen habt dann schreibt
mir bei Instagram ich heiße dort Laser
Luca ich gehe dann in letzter Zeit ein
bisschen häufiger mal auf die Ems ein
und ansonsten lass gerne Daumen hoch
unter dem Video hier da wenn es euch
gefallen hat abonniert meinen Kanal und
klickt auf die Glocke weitere Videos
nichts verpassen schreibt eure Ansichten
zu den verschiedenen Fragen vielleicht
mal unten in die Kommentare ich hoffe
euch hat das Gameplay gefallen und diese
Art des Videos ansonsten sehen wir uns
morgen im neuen Video wieder haut rein
ciao